we've created such a perfect fog these
days like really the fog has
been it's become such a the fog is such
a business every little thing that they
can that that can be created to take
away your attention from uh or that can
take away our attention from figuring
out who we are or like kind of
spelunking inside of ourselves and
trying to get some answers um has really
been created it's almost it's pretty
masterful how much has been created out
here on the outside to keep our
attention um away from delving inside of
ourselves well you know attention is the
basic currency right everyone fights for
it and it's incredibly valuable and it
it certainly is the case
that it's also very tempting to turn
your attention
to things that grasp your short-term
interest rather than say pursuing the
causes of negative emotion that's a
that's a good example and of course we
have massive corporations working night
and day to continually attract our
attention and there's something sinister
about that obviously but but you can't
exactly lay responsibility at their feet
because there isn't that there's a
tremendous overlap between educating
people informing them and and making
them attend to you and and the lines
between all of those things are very F
foggy let's say and difficult to lay out
it's certainly the case that one of the
ways that you can keep yourself in a fog
about yourself is by
distracting is through distraction with
external uh with anything in the
external world and obviously computer
technology cell phones games well not
negative in and of themselves
perhaps are there at any moment to
distract you any moment yeah there yeah
the little things that are time
consumers like yeah it's yeah there's
companies there are businesses where
that is their that's their MO that's
their business is to get your attention
everything's trying to get our attention
sometimes I worry that the forces that
are out there that have like started to
you know really create algorithms even
on how to get our attention and how to
keep it that those forces are stronger
than our human abilities to to keep them
away from us do you feel like that
that's true or do you feel like that
that's just fear I think I really do
believe that that's true I look as far
as I can tell we are teaching computers
to to read our minds as fast as we
possibly can and they're way better at
it than they were 10 years ago and
they're going to be so much better at it
in 5 years that we won't even be able to
imagine it and when I say read our minds
I'm not talking about something magical
but oh yeah for example talking about
like guess what's it's not like like
they're going to guess what we're
thinking or guess what we want for
dinner or anything like that probably
well they might but they won't do it by
directly reading our brain waves or
anything like that um they'll they're
already algorithms that Target
advertisements to send at you are pretty
good at deciding what it is that you're
motivated to pursue and now I actually
just got an ad on my phone for your new
book actually so yeah oh well good so
I'm involved in same process the same
nefarious process I'm just joking that
that I think it's Facebook but I might
be wrong about this that owns Oculus and
the headset the VR headset company now
you can you can track IM movements with
uh VR headset and psychologists use the
tracking of eye movements to map
attention in high detail now look if you
look at our eyes you see that there's a
colored circle and a dark circle in the
middle and then that's surrounded by
white and that makes your eye very
visible to other people animals too but
to other people particularly human eyes
are quite unique in that regard and it
looks like we've evolved to have highly
visible eyes and the reason for that is
that other we communicate with other
people and they can read our motivations
by watching our eyes so if you stand in
the corner and you look up at nothing in
the sky and you stand there long enough
someone else will join you and then if
there's two people then there'll be 10
right away and the reason for that is
that we and this is again something
uniquely human we attend to where other
people Point their
eyes assuming that if they're interested
in it we might be interested in it too
and so that's and human beings are
visual animals about half our brain is
is taken up with visual processing we're
much more visual than virtually any
other animal and so computers are soon
going to be able to track where we place
our eyes which of course advertisers are
incredibly interested in and that's
going to speed up the ability of of
high-powered computational devices to
understand human beings as a group but
also each of us individually to an
immense degree an immense degree and so
and I I think we're probably 10 years
away from computers that understand us
better than we understand ourselves AI
machines are going to get extremely good
at this because it's so lucrative to to
be able to gauge attention there's
there's nothing that's more valuable
than that and so do you feel like it
should do you feel like there should be
le it's hard to say there should be
legislation because I hate to put
anything on the you know that the go
it's the government's responsibility but
should there be like rules or
legislation between
allowing computers and AI to get that
advanced or is it still just fall on the
feet of us as humans just to battle kind
of the Dark Arts of of of these machines
that can sort of like take us into a
trance and then monetize the trance at
the same
time I think I think that legislation in
some senses it's going to be playing
catchup and it's going to be farther and
farther behind all the time because this
is moving so fast and with such power
and it's so distributed that no one is
going to be able to even keep track of
it much less regulate it I mean the the
the the interconnected environment is
changing so rapidly that even if you're
reasonably techsavvy you can't keep up
with all the major changes and there's
there's no evidence whatsoever that
that's going to do anything but
accelerate
and so I can't see how legislators have
the ghost of a chance at keeping up with
this even if they knew what to Target or
what to legislate yeah and you know more
and more Engineers are I think China now
graduates more Engineers every year than
the United States has Engineers oh yeah
China you could be eight years old and
China and be a damn engineer I've been
over there and I've seen a bro I've seen
a six-year-old build a damn bridge in
front of me you know what I'm saying
they they're highly capable yes well in
lots of other cultures are coming online
very rapidly and so we're well and
there's no shortage of unbelievably
proficient amateurs online as well and
and and programming and and so we ain't
seen nothing yet and I really do believe
computers are going to your computer is
going to understand you so well I think
it it won't be long till it knows what
you're going to do more accurately than
you do I think that's already true to
some degree but well then we're at a
real loss because then if I've been
afraid to make a plan for myself in my
life and I've been afraid and I've been
living in the fog and I've been just you
know kind of Sid stepping really putting
my [__] pants on as a human and
taking some action if I'm in that fog
and then the computer is able to figure
out what I'm going to do before I've
even done it but I haven't even made a
plan then surely the computer's going to
make a plan for me it feels like I think
the computer is making a plan for you
all the time already when by default
look that's exactly what advertising is
is advertising makes a plan for you it's
there's no difference between those two
things except maybe one of
sophistication so you know I mean is
when you're watching something and an ad
pops up that's a little world that you
could visit and The Advertiser obviously
wants you to visit that and the the
problem there cuz you might think well
it would be really good the computer can
help you make a plan but I think what's
more likely to happen because at least
to begin with the computer is going to
be paid so to speak by the advertisers
to capitalize on your short-term
impulsivity is that ever more attractive
distractions are going to be dangled in
front of you and that's and that that's
likely to keep you in the fog and what
can I do like to kind of are we going to
start to see like new parts of like new
like small societies form of people that
don't want to be influenced by
technology or you know what do you what
do you feel like some of the future
looks like as far as trying to retain
some sense of of holding on to my
attention and using it for myself as
opposed to letting it be used by outside
influences does that make any sense or
not yes yes well look there's another
rule I suppose a dictum
perhaps that if you don't have your own
story then you're going to be a bit
player in someone else's story okay so
let's talk about that fog again so let's
say because of the reasons you already
laid out you don't want to make your
conditions for failure conscious cuz
then you know when you're failing and
that hurts you don't want to um make
your plans for the future too clear
because then if you then if you don't
attain what you're
looking for it's very clear that you've
lost it which is somewhat different than
failure right um and then there's also
the pro problem that if you make your
motives clear to other people then they
really have the ammunition to hurt you
because like I can hurt you by depriving
you of what you want but I can hurt you
even better if I really know what you
want and can deprive you of that so you
have reasons to keep these things
unclear but then and then you but the
problem then is is that you don't have a
a a Direction that's powerful right
because you're not Consulting yourself
watching yourself learning about
yourself figuring out who you are and
figuring out what kind of route through
life you would have to take to be
engaged okay so then you get weak
because you're not integrated you're all
over the place you're scattered um well
then anybody
who is has power for one reason or
another can compete with you for your
own attention and win and so if you
don't have your own plan painful as it
is to develop one partly because you
have to take your own inadequacies into
account oh yes and you also mentioned
you know you you posit an ideal this is
what I want or this is who I could be
the farther away that is from you the
more inadequate you feel in relationship
to it you know so that's another reason
to avoid it but yes well that's why
every ideal is a judge there's no
getting away from that now if it's too
much for you I might say well make a
lesser ideal like try to pursue
something that doesn't intimidate you
into paralysis right start with
something closer that's more manageable
huh so you can even prove to yourself
that you can do it exactly well what you
really want to do is you want to lay out
a a plan that has a pretty highend aim
but that also consists of steps that
aren't too intimidating that that so you
have to ask yourself um I would like to
do this um I should do it
but would I do it and the answer is
likely to be no often because you know
what you're like you're supposed to go
to the gym but you don't it's like okay
well maybe you won't go to the gym but
maybe you'd walk half a block every
second day something like that and you
have to ask yourself I read about this
in the first chapter about the advantage
of being a fool you know if you notice
that you're not so good at something
then you can calibrate down the goal
until a fool like you can manage it and
then you can attain it and then you're
not quite so much of a fool and so okay
so you have to build a plan I have a
tool for that that I often recommend for
people called
self-authoring yeah yeah yeah I'm very
familiar with it okay well it and it is
it it it was developed in an attempt to
help people write out well an account of
themselves past present and future but
relevant to this discussion is to to
make a plan it's like what is it that
you need to thrive in the world or at
least not to become bitter and if you
don't have your own plan that you're
committed to right and honestly
committed to what that means is that you
will be the pawn of other people's
decisions especially now more than ever
it feels like do you think that that's
true well that's that that certainly
seems to be the conclusion we're
reaching in the course of this
conversation it's like as the powers
around you become more and more invasive
but also also of more utility to you to
some degree I mean we don't want to be
completely negative about computational
power wouldn't be having this discussion
without it but as the p as the forces
around you have more and more capacity
to grip your attention it stands to
reason that you're going to have to be
the captain of your own ship to a
greater and greater degree otherwise you
you'll fall you'll fall prey to those
who wish to monetize your attention so
it's time for it's time to make a plan
if you haven't made a plan it's time to
have a plan it's a really it's a really
good time to have a goal and to have a
plan hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this
one